teachers unions across america resist
school openings
democrats prepare for trump's senate
impeachment trial and 100 politico
staffers winds their publisher the
political print at a column
by me i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
ben well speaking of which if you
haven't gotten a vpn yet you really
should i mean how many times do i have
to tell you that expressive vpn is
indeed
the best at vpn now maybe you have some
questions like did you believe a vpn
isn't for you because you can use the
internet just fine without a vpn
wrong you are the reality is that
everybody can still
link your online traffic to your actual
isp and then it is not hard to find
everything out about you
anytime you go online your internet
service provider can see every single
site you are visiting are you confused
about how
expressive vpn works well expressvpn is
an app for computers and smartphones
it encrypts your network data reroutes
it through a secure server that means
you can use the internet more
anonymously without having your activity
tracked
do you think vpns are complex only for
tech experts wrong again
they are not with expressivevpn you
launch the app you tap one button you
are now protected it really is
that simple i trust expressvpn to
protect my online data because they are
rated number one
by cnet and wired they stand for my
values and with yours too now is the
time for you to take a stance take back
your privacy at expressvpn.com get three
extra months for free on a one-year
package again
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com to get
three extra months for free visit
expressvpn.com
right now to get started okay so let's
talk
kovid for a few moments here so right
now covet continues to spread across
the country if you look at the latest
statistics actually covet seems to be a
little bit on the wane
that is true both in terms of infections
and in terms of deaths the high number
of
detected infections in the united states
came around the first week of january
uh according to worldometers january 8th
we had about 308 thousand diagnosed
cases of covid
in the united states today we are down
to about half that about 152
000 diagnosed cases of covet in the
united states the same
thing seems to be true of deaths the
high in deaths was
again right around that middle of
january and january 12th january 11th
january 8th you're talking about 4 000
deaths a day now
we are dropping slightly not not hugely
but slightly
down to about 3 500 3 400 deaths a day
the real worry right now when it comes
to covet is the possibility of
new variants there are a bunch of
variants that apparently are already
present in the united states
we are trying to shut down travel from
south africa for example is something
joe
biden has done president biden he's also
attempting to shut down travel from
places like brazil the reality is these
variants are probably already in the
united states because the united states
is so open to travel we are not new
zealand we didn't shut off our travel
because we are
in fact the largest economy on the face
of the earth with lots and lots of
international travel we are not a tiny
island in the middle of nowhere with
about seven citizens and some sheep
so anybody who tries to compare how new
zealand handled the pandemic with how
the united states handled the pandemic
is really fooling themselves and again
just just
as a general rule when we talk about
which countries have handled the
pandemic worst versus which countries
have handled the pandemic the best
when people say the united states has
handled the pandemic worse than any
other country that is just not true
in terms of deaths per million
population
the united states is not in fact at the
top of the list
the united states currently ranks about
11th on that list behind countries like
belgium
and slovenia and czechia and the uk and
italy
the united states ranks just above
places like bulgaria hungary
spain and peru right so we will see how
things progress because mexico
is also getting hit really hard they are
rising on the list pretty quickly okay
all of which is to say that nobody has a
wonderful handle on covet and nobody is
going to have a wonderful handle on
covet until the vaccinations
become prevalent enough that they are
able to overtake the virus and that is
the problem with these variants so what
we are finding
is that the vaccines apparently are
still effective on the various
covet variants but those variants are
also significantly more transmissible
even more transmissible
than the original virus itself and that
of course was the real danger of the
virus
the virus was more deadly than the flu
you're still figuring out whether it was
three times more deadly than the flu or
five times more deadly than the flu
and it really did vary widely by age but
when it comes to the transmissibility
that was the major difference between
covid and the flu right even greater
than the than the
problem of the of the deadliness of the
disease was the fact that it was
spreading
so fast amongst a huge percentage of the
population
well scientists are now worried that
these variants are even more
transmissible
caitlin rivers epidemiologists at johns
hopkins at bloomberg school of health
said we're definitely on a downward
slope i'm worried the new variants will
throw us a curveball in late february or
march
which is why it is very very important
that we ramp up the vaccine distribution
as soon as humanly possible like as in
right now nationwide according to the
new york times a couple days ago new
coronavirus cases have fallen 21
in the last two weeks according to new
york times database some experts have
suggested this could mark the start
of a shifting course after nearly four
months of ever worsening case totals
this week the university of washington
institute for health metrics and
evaluation which puts out a predictive
model that is widely used for planning
including by some government agencies
released a projection saying new cases
in the united states would decline
steadily
from now on and so we've seen the worst
of this thing according to them
but with new viral variants surging in
places like britain ireland south africa
and northern brazil
some people are suggesting that maybe
we're seeing a lull before there is
another wave
of the virus which again tranche out
those vaccines as fast
as humanly possible would be the goal
here
now there is a conflicting message that
has been coming out from the biden
administration that conflicting message
is that the united states has handled
this horribly and we need to centralize
all power in the federal government and
two
is we really don't know what the hell
we're doing right this is the
the difficulty with actually running the
government as opposed to sitting outside
the government and complaining
about the government if you are joe
biden and you spent the last year and a
half
or really a year talking about how
terrible the trump administration is
doing
handling this virus if you spent the
last several months talking about how
trump is solely responsible for the vast
spread across the land he did say that
during the campaign right every death is
on donald trump and all of this
when you enter office you better have a
plan there's only one problem your plan
is not very good
it also happens to be the case that the
media's reliance on dr anthony fauci is
the font of all wisdom
is wrong-headed it was wrong-headed from
the start fought she has made a bunch of
mistakes along the way again i don't
think that fauci
is a badly motivated human being or
anything i do think that anthony fauci
uh has gotten high on his own fumes a
little bit and this is a person
who definitely believes his own press in
a major way by the way
the the the guy is pretty well rewarded
he is the highest paid employee in the
entire united states federal government
apparently according to adam
androzewski over at forbes.com
apparently he made 417 000
in 2019 that is the latest year for
which federal salaries are available
that made him the highest paid
out of all four million federal
employees in the united states which is
pretty astonishing actually by the way
he uh
he has complained before about people
saying that he is um
that he is you know a rich guy and he's
he makes too much money
he's like no no i'm a public employee
yeah a public employee who's making an
access of what the president of the
united states makes so i mean there is
that as well in any case
anthony fauci was speaking to to davos
right davos is this international
gathering of the hoi polloi and here was
anthony fauci explaining that america's
big problem is that it's
its response was politicized and that
was destructive to a unified approach
now here's the problem with that again
to to pretend that all of the united
states has handled coronavirus similarly
is just a lie and when you say that the
us would have been better off with this
giant top-down unified approach
i'm wondering what your evidence of that
is what would it look like a top-down
unified approach would it look like
california which is getting absolutely
shellacked day after day today
in terms of number of deaths per day
california is
far outpacing the rest of the united
states it is not close
right now california is experiencing in
excess of 400 deaths a day
compared to second by the way is new
york right new york you remember got hit
in the first wave well now new york is
having a second wave they had 217 deaths
yesterday
according to world odometers florida
which has the same population as new
york but a lot more old people
is down to 153 texas is right after that
so here is the bottom line when you say
that you want a centralized unified
approach
what you are ignoring is the fact that
the fact that that the the
sort of non-centralized approach of the
united states has allowed for a bunch of
states to handle this better than other
states and
people did not handle this all the same
and considering how
poorly places like new york and
california apparently have handled it
that's not a bad thing here is fauci
though talking about how we need more
government centralization by the way if
you think the government has done like
an
unbelievable job here let me just point
out the government essentially had a
couple of jobs one was to prevent the
spread they did not actually do that
despite all of the lockdowns
two was that they were going to tranch
out the vaccines okay they've been
really slow on that
for all the talk about operation warp
speed it was the private industry it was
private industry that developed the
vaccine not the united states federal
government
in any case here is anthony fauci
talking about how you need more
centralization of control
when public health issues become
politically
charged like wearing a mask or not
becomes a political statement it is you
cannot imagine
how destructive that is to any unified
public health message you know what's
really amazing about
all the masking talk and it's all about
trump and people didn't take masking
seriously enough
the rates of mass usage in the united
states are extraordinarily high
and much higher than parts of europe if
you ask people to self-report whether
they wear a mask most of the time or all
the time
in excess of 80 of americans say they
wear a mask most or all of the time when
they are in crowded spaces
okay the problem here is not mass
compliance la
had mask mandates in place for months i
mean literally starting about
a month and a half after after the
beginning of the pandemic
when fauci shifted on his original eye
and said oh no no you should wear masks
everybody in l.a was wearing masks
and la is just getting absolutely
decimated right now
the the the big lie here which is that
if you had just listened to the public
health experts and now if you listen
more to the public health experts and
you listen even more to the public
health experts
we'll just keep doubling down on this
that would have fixed everything if we
listened to anthony fausch nobody would
have worn a mask at the beginning and
if we listen to anthony fauci then we
never would have opened the schools
and if we had listened to anthony fauci
we would have thought herd immunity was
kicking in at 70
percent i mean i'm sorry but the the
idea that everybody is wrong for not
listening to me is such a
it's true on all sides of the aisle when
it comes to politics but it's ugly
and the reality is people aren't going
to listen to you
and you're just gonna have to deal with
that because in a free country that is
how things work
the kind of bizarre longing for a
top-down dictatorial mindset when it
comes to this stuff is really weird
it's i think what underlies so much of
the media's hatred of florida
i'm looking at the statistics right now
in terms of deaths per million
in the united states death per million
by state where do you think florida
ranks
if you looked at just the the media
coverage where would you think that
florida ranked in terms of deaths per
million population in the united states
you'd probably think that it ranks in
the top two maybe the top 10
maybe the top 20 maybe the top 25
florida ranks 26th in america in terms
of deaths per million
but if you actually look at how the
media covers that's because desantis has
taken a decentralized approach
so it seems almost as though when it
comes to how so many members of the
public health establishment and
democrats
tend to think of public health they
think of public health in the same way
they think of government
generally which is government is always
the solution centralized government is
always the solution
and if it fails it's because we need to
we need to centralize to centralize
harder
that is the only way that we are going
to be able to to overcome the pandemic
okay we'll get to why this is such
nonsense errant nonsense in just one
second
first let's talk about the fact that
it's been a
long and difficult year but now it's the
beginning of new year and you're
thinking about things that are on your
to-do list things you need to get done
one of those things is getting life
insurance well policy genius can help
you cross it off with ease
policy genius makes it easy for you to
compare more than 30 top insurers all at
once and save over 50
in the process plus there's no hassle
because their licensed experts work for
you not the insurance companies here's
how it works first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day you might even be eligible to skip
that in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process
they will take care of everything for
you soup to nuts that kind of service
has earned policy genius a five-star
rating across over 1 600 reviews
on trustpilot and google make this
theory you finally cross life insurance
off your list get protection for your
loved ones go to policygenius.com get
started
you could say 50 or more by comparing
quotes and start the new year with one
less thing to worry about policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice
and incredibly important to get it right
okay so our public health officials they
just keep saying why don't you listen to
us why don't you listen to us more why
don't you listen to us more
maybe because you've been wrong a
thousand times speaking of public health
officials who have been wrong a thousand
times here's anthony fauci
walking back his original assessment
which is that a hundred million people
were going to be vaccinated in the first
hundred days
of the biden administration here he was
on sunday walking that back and being
not what i actually meant is that we
will be
tranching out a hundred million vaccine
shots remember it takes
two to fully vaccinate somebody so
there's a rather large i mean he was off
by a factor of 50
and his original estimate here here was
here's the world's greatest doctor
anthony fauci
let me clarify that because there was a
little bit of a misunderstanding
what we're talking about is a hundred
million shots in individuals
so a shots as in other words when you
get down to let's say
a certain part of the hundred days at
the end of 100 days you're going to have
some people
who will have gotten both shots and some
will still be on their first shots what
the president is saying a hundred
million
shots in the arms of people within 100
days oh weird because uh like a week ago
joe biden was saying it was going to be
100 million people vaccinated within 100
days okay so really well done everybody
everybody's an amazing job here
and meanwhile it turns out that that
centralized government policy has been
the greatest driver of poverty
in half a century according to bloomberg
the end of 2020 brought the sharpest
rise in u.s poverty rate since the 1960s
economist bruce meyer from the
university of chicago and james sullivan
from the university of notre dame
found that the poverty rate increased by
2.4 percentage points during the latter
half of 2020
as the us continued to suffer the
economic impacts from covet 19. that
percentage point rise is nearly double
the largest annual increase in poverty
since the 1960s
this means an additional 8 million
people nationwide are now considered
poor
moreover the poverty rate for black
americans is estimated to have jumped by
5.4 percentage points
or by 2.4 million individuals the
scholars findings put the rate at 11.8
percent in december
while poverty is down from readings more
than 15 percent a decade earlier the new
estimates suggest
the annual census bureau tally due in
september will be higher than the last
official pre-pandemic level of 10.5
percent
in 2019. so the poverty rate has
absolutely skyrocketed
we have also seen a massive massive
amount of drug
overdose increases a massive increase in
suicide
the number of young americans who are
going to die of causes other than covet
19 during this period
may at the end of the day actually
outpace the number of young americans
meaning americans under the age of 40
who actually die from covid
hey the overdose figures are really
really brutal
okay so there is that so our experts
basically locked down the entire economy
created the sharpest rise in the poverty
rate in 50 years
made the the death rate for young
americans much higher than it otherwise
would have been
instead of simply saying okay everybody
who's the age of 65 we need to protect
those people and everybody else
needs to go out and get back to work as
soon as humanly possible with the
protections that are available which was
always the best policy
but anybody who pursued that policy was
ripped up and down because we need of
course
more centralized control the best
governor in america supposedly was going
to be people
was gavin newsom in california andrew
cuomo in new york
phil murphy in new jersey everybody who
locked down the hardest
everyone who locked down super duper
duper hard these were the best governors
in the world and we need more
centralized control
just like that that is definitely going
to fix
what ails the united states of america
really
i mean this is this is what they are
calling for which is frankly kind of
astonishing
speaking of which joe biden has now
shifted his tune on all of this it turns
out that again when you sit outside the
government of your campaigning it is
very easy to talk about
how what we need is more centralized
government control as soon as joe biden
is actually in charge as soon as he is
president
then it's like you know i'm gonna run
headlong from responsibility for uh any
of this
i'm just gonna i'm gonna stand over here
and um didn't remember that time i told
you guys that this is gonna be really
rough and really bad
now give me credit for being honest with
you okay except for how you blamed every
covet death on donald trump if you blame
every call of death on donald trump
that suggests the person who's the
president of the united states is now
responsible for what happens
with covet once they become the head of
the the head of the executive branch
here is joe biden running headlong from
that responsibility saying oh you know
what
what i actually meant it's going to take
a lot of time for us to crush the
pandemic oh
that's that's what i meant well i'm
going to shut down the virus but not
i never said i'd do it in two months i
said it took a long time to get here
it's going to take a long time to beat
it and so we have millions of people out
there who are
who have the virus we're just for the
first day i think correct me if i'm
wrong i've been doing other things
this morning speaking with foreign
leaders but one of the things i think
this is one of the first days that the
numbers actually come down the number of
deaths
and the number on a daily basis and the
number of hospitalizations etc
it's going to take time it's going to
take a heck of a lot of time
oh well i mean why don't you set those
expectations below the floor
i also love how he's taking credit for
the numbers coming down he's he's been
in office for it is now
january 26th he's been in office for six
days so he wants it both ways
on the one hand i'm not responsible for
anything that is happening on the other
hand i'm responsible for
all the deaths coming down and we'll see
how this works out for him meanwhile
biden has revised his estimate remember
he kept saying that he wanted to do a
million shots a day it turns out that
at the time we were doing 1.1 million
shots a day so he's actually talking
about reducing the number of shots
every day and he's like look how brave i
am measure the injury room
look i i i have a plan come on man come
on and if you asked about it come on man
well now he's revised and once again and
he says actually
we're going to be ramping this thing up
to 1.5 million shots a day
now frankly that shouldn't be
particularly difficult the reality is we
are currently doing 1.3 million shots a
day
in any case here was joe biden now
revising his estimate up
i promised that we would get at least a
a 100 million vaccinations that's not
people because sometimes you need more
than one shot the vaccination
but a hundred thousand a hundred million
shots in people's arms of the vaccine
i think with the grace of god the good
will of neighbor and the crick not
rising as the old saying goes
i think we may be able to get that to
thou 1.5 million a day rather than 1
million a day
but we have to meet that goal of a
okay again he keeps saying a million a
day we're already doing a million a day
dude
already we were before you took office
and then biden says he's asked okay so
um
when is everyone who wants a vaccine
going to be able to get
a vaccine and he's like well how about
like sometime this spring
oh that's helpful okay so honestly i
have a fairly large personal stake
uh in this particular question i have
two parents who are both right about to
turn 65 so they are just under the age
cutoff
i am desperate to get them in the
vaccine i would love to get them the
vaccine they are concerned about covet
they should be concerned about covet
they are not in the in the highest risk
bracket and again for for people who are
otherwise healthy and are 64 years old
the risk of covet is not you know a
hundred out of a thousand are gonna die
it's more like four out of a thousand
three out of a thousand are gonna
but those are not stats you wanna take
anyway so i would love to get my parents
the vaccine like as soon as humanly
possible so i actually have a personal
stake like millions and millions and
millions of americans do
and making sure that we can get the
vaccine as soon as possible so he has
asked okay so when will anyone who wants
the vaccine be able to get a vaccine
he's like well sometime you know
sometime
appreciate it well i feel the confidence
rising wow i feel so much better about
things now
here is joe biden taking control
roughly when do you think anyone who
wants one would be able to get it in the
summer oh i know i i think it'll be this
spring
i think we'll be able to do that this
spring and uh but it's going to be a
logistical
uh challenge that exceeds anything we've
ever tried
in this country but i think we can do
that i feel confident that
by summer we're going to be well on our
way to heading toward
herd immunity and increasing the access
for people who
aren't on the first on the list all the
way going down to
uh children meanwhile the the captains
of science first of all
if you have young kids there's a really
good case to be made especially if we
have tranched out the vaccine to adults
if you have very young kids there's a
very solid case who made you shouldn't
really bother getting your kid a vaccine
uh and that's not an anti-vaccination
point that is just a
point of fact because children are not
being gravely affected by this disease
i'm talking about young children not
teenagers
okay so the idea that we're going to
like start by the way this is what the
teachers unions want
i can get to that in a second there are
a lot of teachers unions right now who
are actually pushing that every child
like
my four-year-old would have to get a
vaccine shot for kovid my four-year-old
is at zero risk statistically speaking
when i say zero i mean so close to zero
that it effectively is zero
of god forbid dying from covet and these
teachers unions never want to reopen and
that is the main point when it comes to
the politics of covet the notion that
it's just being driven by the science
it's just nonsense it's just nonsense
i'm sorry
all over the country there are people
who are taking differential approaches
to covet all over the world people are
taking differential approaches
to covid the notion that you can just
point at science to justify whatever
your dumb agenda item
is of the day is just not the case we'll
get some more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that there are a lot of people
who are dropping off packages at your
front door
these days a lot happens at that front
door in my house we get food deliveries
and we're getting
groceries we're getting packages
delivered from from
various companies and and then i have to
keep track of my kids i mean i've got my
kids who are trying to run out the front
door because they want to play in the
front yard and
there's all sorts of stuff happening in
my house i need ring devices on my house
that's why when we moved one of the
first things my wife did she turned to
me and she said we need to get ring
on the house now is the perfect time to
upgrade your doorstep with a ring
video doorbell with ring you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door from
anywhere
right on the phone you're never gonna
miss a visitor whether it's your
neighbor your dinner
your groceries you can keep those
packages and delivery safe with motion
detection you'll get notified even if
they don't ring the doorbell if someone
stops by with something going on
ring will let you know i love having
that ring video doorbell it makes sure
that i can keep track
not just of what's going on on my front
porch i've got ring devices everywhere
so i can keep track of my kids
as they are running around and making
trouble right now you too can get a
special offer on the ring welcome kit
at ring.com it comes with that ring
video doorbell 3 and chime pro it's the
perfect way to upgrade your front door
and start that ring experience
head on over to ring.com that is ring
dot com
slash ben okay speaking of the idea that
that
is promoted by folks on the left just
follow the science
so gavin newsom has now has now canceled
california's stay-at-home orders across
the state
so that will allow restaurants and
businesses in some counties to reopen
outdoor dining and other services now
there was never any scientific data to
back
the closing of outdoor dining in the
first place there's zero data that
suggests that outdoor dining is a cheap
vector of covert transmission
but now magically the week after joe
biden takes office
gavin newsom is now going to redo all of
the regulations in california
surrounding coven how strange how
strange i mean like wow
must be that the science is dictating
that right there's only one problem the
science is absolutely not dictating that
he lifted california's emergency stays
according to you know weiss who's been
following this stuff closely
he lifted california's emergency stay at
home orders with 50
less 50 fewer icu beds available now
than the day he implemented it okay so
literally the day he implemented it
there were there were a certain number
of icu beds available pretty high number
of icu beds available and he implemented
the curfew and indoor dining and all the
rest of it
we now have like a much much higher
percentage
of california's icu is filled by covert
positive cases and now he's like you
know what
gonna reopen almost as though the
science isn't dictating this the
politics is dictating this
but that's always the case okay when it
comes to covet policy
so much of it is driven by politics so
much of it and the most obvious example
of this of course
is the teachers unions so teachers
unions are basically now saying they
just don't want to teach ever again
now for my money i'm fine with that
seriously i hope everybody homeschools i
hope everybody pulls their kids out of
schools puts them in parochial schools
puts them in private schools
like take the money out of the out of
the public school system take these
teachers unions at their words
like they don't want to teach fine i
don't want you teaching my kids because
i think that you guys are
basically garbage added generally anyway
i think that the teachers unions protect
the worst teachers at the expense of the
best teachers
i think that you value seniority over
quality in your teachers
i think that you create ridiculous
educational missions that have very
little to do with the education of the
american public school child
so you guys don't want to come into
school good news millions and millions
of americans have realized over the past
year
they're not sure they want you teaching
their kids but if you are a member of
the democratic party
and your big push is that public
education done by teachers unions is one
of the jewels of the american system
then um wouldn't you stand up to the
teachers unions at this point and say
and say you know guys you really should
go back to work
there's a new study out that new study
suggests
that there really is no elevated risk
for teachers above the general
population that of course is not a shock
at all
we've known this for quite a while that
there really is no elevated public risk
in terms of the in terms of teachers
over the general population
in fact you'd imagine they're probably
at less risk generally especially if
they're teaching young kids
young kids are not transmitting this
disease in the same way that older
children are
it also happens to be the case that
younger teachers right if you're a 22
year old teacher
for second graders your level of risk is
really really minimal
it's much lower than you going to a bar
that same night but in a bunch of
different states we've got
bars that are open and schools that are
closed which is madness
according to the hill the chicago's
teachers union voted to defy chicago
public schools reopening plans for
teachers and staff due to coronavirus
concerns the union announced on sunday
the teachers union
for the nation's third largest school
district decided to allow all educators
to conduct work remotely
starting on monday the day kindergarten
through eighth grade staff were expected
to return in person so these are
specifically
teachers for young kids the ctu reported
of its 25 000 members participated in
the electronic vote on thursday friday
saturday
71 of voting members decided to deny the
district's current plan to come back to
in-person learning
a ctu release said it means the
overwhelming majority of you have chosen
safety
cps did everything possible to divide us
by instilling fear through threats of
retaliation
he still chose unity solidarity and to
collectively act as one by the way this
just demonstrates
once again public sector unions are a
blight on the american political system
public sector unions would bargain
collectively
against the taxpayer and pay off the
politicians to bargain on their own
behalf
it's one of the most corrupt deals in
all of american politics maybe the most
corrupt deal
essentially you now have unions that pay
to get politicians elected they then
negotiate with the politicians
against the taxpayer and the politicians
use the union money in order to get
reelected
it's truly impressive legal grift the
chicago sometimes it labeled the vote
unusually close for ctu labor actions
because 94
of voting members usually decide when to
strike
the chicago district official sent a
letter to families on sunday saying the
return date for teachers will be delayed
until wednesday
to allow for more time for negotiations
and to avoid risking disruption to
student learning
now again there's no science to back
this the science to suggest that these
teachers are at risk and that they can't
come back
until x y or z it's just nonsense it's
not true
in fact there are serious questions as
to whether this particular teacher's
strike is legal
under the regulations but it's not just
chicago's teachers unions it's in ohio
as well
according to wtol the largest teachers
unions in the state are responding after
governor mike dewine announced 96
percent
of public school districts in ohio have
signed a form committing to in-person
learning by march 1st
the unions including the toledo
federation of teachers say in a joint
statement that governor dewine is using
vaccines as a bargaining ship to open
schools by march 1st
the statement says teachers students
families and cities will face dire
consequences if schools are pressured to
reopen before it is safe to do so
okay it's just a lie it's not true okay
so they're pushing that
new jersey teachers they say that they
don't want to come back
until every single student in these
schools is tested
again that is not first of all the false
positive rate on the test alone
would probably make it impossible to
open the schools but
beyond that are you insane okay the
children are not the chief vector of the
transmission
there's more danger of you hanging out
in the teachers union with the other
teachers than of you teaching the kids
okay perhaps the the greatest example of
this insanity is
members of the washington teachers union
claiming
that reopening schools for in-person
learning is an example of white
supremacy
and saying that if we value the mental
health of students that is a form of
white privilege
according to the daily wire echoing
comments made by the chicago teachers
union months ago that reopening schools
for in-person instruction is both racist
and sexist
the president of the pasco association
of educators scott wilson made a series
of unhinged controversial remarks during
a pasco school board meeting according
to our friends at jason rant over at
ktth
the comments were captured on video as
the board of education conducts its
meetings on zoom
amidst the coronavirus pandemic this
particular teachers union head
compared the effort to reopen schools to
the riot at the u.s capitol
wilson said there are decisions to be
made you stand on the lawn of the us
capital as people break down barriers
and head to the doors do you follow
you stand at the governor's mansion the
crowd breaks down barriers to enter the
grounds
do you follow or do you choose a
different way we must not ignore the
culture of white supremacy
and white privilege he said we speak of
equity we speak
of the care of students yet we listen
and attend to voices saying reopen
everything i'm free to breathe
supporting white privilege okay in
reality the people who are the most
harmed
by all of these stay-at-home orders have
been children who are black and hispanic
because disproportionately kids who are
black and hispanic go to public schools
and particularly their parents need them
in the public school so they can go work
because in single parent households
which are disproportionately in black
and hispanic families
if you can't drop your kid at school how
exactly going to go to work that day
and this is madness so joe biden was
asked about all this right so joe biden
gets asked about
the teachers unions and whether they
should return to schools and joe biden
sidesteps the question
because again one of the it's amazing
you hear all the time about the
corruption of money and politics you
heard this from the bernie sanders crew
well there's so much money on politics
it's so terrible also i would love to
receive
a 100 million dollar investment from the
teachers unions
to go and don't knock for me i mean it's
just it's incredible
they're explicitly bargaining against
the interests of their own students
and then joe biden is out there
defending them
and it is a high level form of
corruption right in plain sight
the fact that labor unions have this
much power with our federal and state
governments is
nuts it's nuts and the fact that the
national labor relations act is so
biased in favor
of collective bargaining that would be
considered collusion if it were done
by employers but as soon as it is done
by employees it is now considered not
collusion but
something magical the nlra is a terrible
piece of legislation
okay but put that aside the very
existence of public sector unions
is in in most cases a blight on the
republic but here is joe biden
this is just an example refusing to
condemn teachers unions that are cutting
directly here's captain science here
as kids are being put out of school all
across the nation
again even though we're reopening
outdoor dining and we're reaping indoor
dining
here's joe biden do you believe
sir that teachers should return to
schools now
i believe we should make
school classrooms safe and secure
for the students for the teachers
and for the the help that's in those
schools
maintaining the facilities we need new
ventilation systems in those schools
we need testing for people coming in and
out of the classes we need testing for
teachers as well as students
and we need the capacity the capacity to
know
that in fact the sa the sick of the
circumstance in the school
is safe and secure for everyone okay so
basically i'm just going to avoid all of
this by the way my kids have been in
school since the beginning of the year
no problem okay my kids are two of them
under the age of seven are in school
and um there's been no problem they've
taken precautions like masking they put
a little plexiglass on the tables the
teachers are there the teachers have not
been infected
but apparently it's the end of the world
again the willingness of the media to
overlook the
insane corruption of keeping millions
and millions tens of millions of school
kids at home
so teachers unions can sit at home
and get rich i mean really the unions
are getting rich not the people who are
members of the unions the unions
themselves
it's super corrupt how tied in is the
biden administration to these unions
so tied in that randy weingarten was
originally considered a possibility for
secretary of education the head of the
american federation of teachers
but here she was this week saying that
she stands behind teachers who are
refusing to go back to school
of course we stand a hundred percent
behind the chicago union but
you know the issue really is you know
just like we said last summer
when we said we would support these
safety
strikes the issue is we know that
in-school learning is really important
and vital for children
and so we are trying to take the steps
in different places to make that happen
okay so yeah those teachers unions
they're all for the students though
they're all for the students okay in a
second we're gonna get to everything
impeachment related because that is now
moving forward first let us talk about
how you can get in better shape this
year so a lot of folks have not been
able to go to the gym gyms have been
closed around
the nation and a lot of folks have been
starting to do all sorts of wonderful
exercise programs at home let me let me
tell you about one
that is just fantastic it's going to get
you in shape and it's not gonna cost you
an
arm and a leg i am talking about echelon
okay echelon offers the next generation
of connected fitness bikes fitness
mirrors rowing machines and their
echelon stride smart treadmill no matter
what your favorite fitness activity
echelon will give you a fun challenging
workout from the comfort of your home
the ex-7s that's echelon's latest
state-of-the-art innovation it takes
cycling to the next level
the ex-7s connected bike it's built with
performance flexibility and durability
in mind it is the bike for competitors
at heart they're world-class instructors
they're going to motivate you
with thousands of daily live and
on-demand studio level classes always
available
when you need them and unlike their
competitors echelon is affordable for
everyone
one membership will let up to five
family members all work out at the same
exact time
you may have noticed their competitors
peloton an
armored leg just a fortune not with
echelon you are getting
amazing quality for a lot less money
right now you can try any echelon
fitness equipment at home
for 30 days i've been using echelon i
want to get back in shape my wife
learned to bake and it's been a problem
for me
i definitely i'm going to jump on that
echelon bike as soon as i get home go to
echelonfit.com that is e-c-h-e-l-o-n-fit
dot com slash man echelon fit.com
ben okay we're gonna get to everything
impeachment related in just one second
first
you may have noticed that daily wire has
made the jump back into the culture okay
the right constantly complains about not
being in the culture
well that means we have to jump in
earlier this month we released our first
film run hide fight exclusively
for daily wire members you can catch it
over at dailywire.com on our mobile app
on our streaming apps at apple tv
and roku if you are not a daily wire
member yet use promo code rhf to get 25
off that is rhf for 25
off now you may have noticed that the
critical reviews on rotten tomato are
negative
well that's not a shock we here at daily
wire we are interested in making stuff
that you love even if the critics hate
it and that is run hide fight a story of
heroism
a story about courage and yeah a story
about how
sometimes you need a good guy with a gun
to stop a bad guy with a gun you can
catch it over at dailywire.com
on our mobile app or on our streaming
apps at apple tv and roku if you are not
a daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25 off that is
rhf run hide fight for 25 percent off
your listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
meanwhile the house impeachment managers
have decided to deliver the articles
to the senate they walked these things
and the articles solemnly over to the
senate chamber apparently only about
three republicans
were there and then the democrats were
very angry that more republicans didn't
show up to receive the articles
of impeachment why aren't they taking
this seriously why aren't they taking
this seriously
well i mean there are a couple reasons
one is that
pretty much everybody can see what this
mostly is this isn't to say there isn't
a case for
convicting trump in the senate you know
liz cheney i think has made that case
what it is to say is that it is pretty
obviously by democrats a political ploy
okay most of what is going on right here
is a political ploy so here is the logic
everybody knows including the democrats
that trump isn't actually going to get
convicted here
he isn't going to get convicted because
the articles of impeachment are not
specific they do not even allege a real
crime
okay when they say that he incited
violence he literally said at that rally
that he wanted people to peacefully
protest now does that mean it was good
what he didn't know
many things can be not good presidents
do not good things i would say 80
of the time they're doing not good
things okay but does that mean that
every single thing that they do
is impeachable conduct now impeach
impeachment again
is a political tool so you can impeach
for anything but typically if you're
going to allege a crime like incitement
you'd actually have to bring the goods
the problem is what is the neutral
standard that is going to be used here
for impeachment
if the neutral standard is going to be a
person
who is an office holder is not allowed
to challenge or doubt the results of an
election
that neutral standard obviously doesn't
hold because we saw several years here
of democrats suggesting the 2016
election was rigged by the russians
okay if the neutral standard is you're
not allowed to use inflammatory language
such that
some bad people could get it in their
heads to go to a bad thing that also is
not going to hold because
as we have seen many times this has
happened on a wide variety of political
perspectives
anybody who has a large enough crowd is
going to have some nuts in the crowd
now again none of that is to say that
trump's rhetoric was good or that trump
saying what he said about the election
wasn't true
was it was somehow true none of it was
okay putting all of that aside
okay the the impeachable conduct here
there's really
not a solid neutral standard of conduct
here that is going to apply and what
i've seen is that the results
of trump's conduct were so egregious
that he requires impeachment
on just a moral level i guess you can
make that case okay but then you would
have to make the case that literally
anybody who uses inflammatory language
in american political life and then
somebody goes and does something bad
even if they didn't call for that person
to do something bad ought to be thrown
out of american public life
and you can see that there are folks who
are extending the logic here so for
example
joe scarborough immediately extended the
logic to josh alley
so josh haley did something i thought
was incredibly cynical right i said it
at the time i thought it was a very
cynical move by josh halley
to suggest that he could challenge
electors or overthrow the results of the
election
by simply suggesting that there was some
sort of vague voter irregularity or
fraud in fact when asked directly
whether there was voter fraud or
regularity sufficient to overthrow
the the electors themselves hallie
demured on that particular question so
it's pretty obvious that what he was
doing was cynical
a cynical action by politicians is not
in fact impeachable action by
politicians
nor is it typically linked to violence
that's what joe scarborough had to say
he said that josh halley
incited the violence right it's not just
trump howling inside of the violence
presumably ted cruz incited the violence
presumably
every single one of the republican
legislators who voted to challenge the
election
incited the violence all of them are
responsible for inciting now
again those things could be bad and also
not inciting a violence
and understand that this is part of a
broader rubric from the left that
anything that they don't like is quote
unquote incitement to violence
you'll notice that the left never holds
that standard with regard to a bernie
sanders supporter shooting up members of
a congressional baseball game
you'll you'll never hear the argument
that barack obama's language with regard
to police
is responsible for a black lives matter
supporter shooting dead six police
officers in dallas in 2016. you won't
hear that
nearly ever you're not gonna hear that
it was democratic views of policing and
race in america that incited
one to two billion dollars worth of
property damage and violence over the
summer
right that's not a standard that is
going to be held here and the idea here
is just that it's it's only
conservatives and republicans who are to
be held
to this particular standard now again i
can think that we all ought to bring
down the temperature and that's fine
right that's fine does that mean that
people ought to be cast out of public
life for using inflammatory language if
so it's going to be difficult to do
politics
in the future in any case here is joe
scarborough basically suggesting it's
not just trump that must go it's every
single person
who supported trump on any level since
the election
i mean he's a seditionist he led an
insurrection he's responsible for cops
being murdered
he's responsible for everything that we
saw he was at the forefront of it
he should be kicked out of the united
states senate
and here's the thing democrats know this
is going nowhere so here is joe biden
yesterday saying you know what
impeachment it has to have well cnn
reports that biden says impeachment has
to happen even though there's not going
to be a conviction
he told me aaron quote just a few
minutes ago i think it has to happen
he said that he did understand the
effect that it could have of course
given that it will
basically be all-consuming for the
senate given however long
it could last but aaron he said he
thinks the effect of that trial for
president trump
former president trump didn't happen
would have a worse effect if it did not
go forward and so
we talked about this of course joe biden
is someone who served in the senate for
a very long time i asked him
if he thinks that donald trump would be
acquitted for a second time
he said that he does not believe 17
republican senators would vote to
convict him
okay so if the conviction is not a real
likelihood then
what is the real goal here right so the
real goal here is twofold
obviously well maybe threefold one is to
cascade republicans as lacking moral
principle if they don't vote to convict
trump after he's already out of office
and again i think that as this thing
drags on more and more americans are
gonna be like why are we bothering with
this
because americans just don't have a
taste for this sort of stuff
after the person is out of office okay
but there are two other goals
here as well okay goal number it's a
win-win for democrats obviously
again this the announcement i'm about to
do here is a pure political analysis it
is not about the morality
of actually holding trump to
to conviction here right holding trump
to conviction i think that reasonable
minds can differ on whether what trump
did constitutes quote unquote
impeachable conduct because again
i have a real tough time suggesting that
just because somebody uses
inflammatory language without actually
inciting violence they're then
responsible for what happens next
i just think that's an unsustainable
standard in american political life but
and again i've been consistent on that
left to right but putting that aside the
actual politics here what are democrats
actually doing here do i think this is
all about principle for democrats no i
really don't think this is all about
principle for democrats
like at all i think for the vast
majority of elected democrats this is
about a win-win scenario
scenario number one trump goes up for
for conviction in the senate it is voted
down
and trump then claims look they tried to
get me again and then
he runs in 2024 which is what democrats
would like right
democrats want trump to run in 2024 they
think he's eminently beatable
last election shows that that is not a a
malformed thought
they believe that trump in a in a
republican primary would still garner 25
of the vote there's every likelihood
that that would happen and so
for them they're like okay so scenario
number one is republicans vote down the
conviction we then get to castigate the
entire republican party as amoral and
immoral
and to boot trump will then run again so
it'll really finish them for years to
come
then there's possibility number two
which is that you somehow get enough
republicans to vote to convict
and trump is barred from holding future
office
okay well then all that would happen
presumably is that trump
would start a third party he'd prop up
some other figure
as the head of that third party and he
would just break the republican party
right down
right down the middle right he's already
talked about starting a patriot party
right he's already talked which by the
way according to some polls is polling
higher than the republican presidential
party would be in 2024 now
again we're four years out but for for
democrats the goal here is chaos
i don't actually believe that this is
about holding people to account for for
most of the elected democrats
i think this is much and these elected
democrats they don't hold anybody to
account
it wouldn't even pass a resolution
censoring johann omar for being an
anti-semite like i just
i don't buy it my opinion of politicians
is so low
i think most of them are politically
motivated i think most of them are
cynical i think most of them are
ambitious
i don't think that they are standing on
some sort of higher principle here in
any case here is chuck schumer
pretending that he stands on higher
principle
we still can look back and we have to
you can't sweep some of these egregious
things under the rug
plain and simple trump was
you know his act on the six was the most
despicable thing any president
has ever done and he is the worst
president
ever and you cannot just let's move on
you got to look back
okay so first of all the reason that
they keep saying they want to look back
is of course and then they can look at
trump and they can keep saying how
wonderful biden is
and that's the goal keep trump as the
specter and then you just say well by
contrast look how normal things are now
look how amazing things are now
also the idea that this is the worst
thing any president has ever done is
make a speech on the washington mall
which you encourage people to peacefully
protest while using inflammatory
language
like of all the things presidents have
done no i i actually don't think
that put aside what these supporters did
what the supporters did is one of the
worst things
in american history right breaching the
actual capital building looking for
blood that's one of the worst things in
american history what trump actually did
that day is that the worst like the
worst thing
the president like frankly i think that
it's worse what he did by calling brad
raffensberger
i think that it's worse what he did by
simply suggesting over and over and over
that the election was stolen for months
on it i think that was worse
one of the worst things the worst thing
a president has ever done we've had
presidents who interned hundreds of
thousands of japanese people
we've had presidents who screened birth
of a nation in the white house
we had presidents who held slaves like
no
no on that one but with that said the
political manipulation here is quite
clear
quick note john roberts the chief
justice of the supreme court normally
would preside over an impeachment trial
he has demured he says i'm not going to
do that
so it's going to be a democrat presiding
over the impeachment trial which just
makes the thing
even more of a circus than it otherwise
would be
okay meanwhile the the censorship in the
media continues a pace so i would be
remiss if i did not mention
uh a story that has continued to play
out for the last couple of weeks and it
is kind of astonishing because
the absolute insanity and immaturity of
some members of the left
it's beyond the pale i have three kids
under the age of seven
they're not the most mature children
right they they're mature for their ages
but when i say mature for their ages
they're almost seven four and less than
one
so not all that mature just in sort of
general human standards
they have significantly more maturity
than the entire combined staff of
political apparently
okay so politico you remember a couple
of weeks ago vast
grief and rage broke out because
politico's playbook had asked me to
write the playbook one day
now that followed on chris hayes writing
the playbook yamiche alcindor from pbs
who's a far left liberal
she had written the playbook don lemon
wrote the playbook
after i did kara swisher who's a
censorious awful leftist columnist for
the new york times she wrote the
playbook
so i wrote the playbook because they
wanted somebody on the right
so i wrote the playbook and the basic
point i made in politico's playbook was
the entire goal of the left seems to be
to lump in everybody on the right with
the capital rider so they can then say
everybody on the right is dangerous and
ban them
right that was my entire point that was
the entire piece
people at political went nuts they had a
staff phone call with 225 members of the
staff most of them from the newsroom
because these are news makers
these people will cover your journalism
and crew they got very angry and they
shouted at the editors but that didn't
work
because the editors were like you know
what we're going to have a lot of people
from a lot of different sides of the
political aisle
and you citing bad old tweets from 2012
that shapiro's already explained
multiple times
that's not gonna do it so what did they
do a hundred staffers decided to go over
the heads of the editors and directly to
the publisher
of politico and whine about this amazing
amazing people
according to the daily beast maxwell
tony who's again one of these censorious
types would love to see nothing better
than all of the folks
on the right d-platformed asap and
always gets the scoop
when far leftists decide that it's time
to try to get somebody canceled
so here is what what the daily beast
reports more than 100
politico staffers signed on to a letter
sent to publisher robert albritton
expressing disgust with allowing
right-wing fire brand ben shapiro to
guest author one
day's edition of the playbook and with
the outlets subsequent handling of the
fallout
one day i wrote a piece for politico
ah peace and a hundred people at
political were like
how dare you
now listen they can't actually they
can't cancel me over politico i don't
work for politico
i don't care i didn't write for politico
because i needed politico's money
and so they can't cancel me that's not
what this is about the the what this is
about is pressuring editors
into never having anybody who's remotely
right-wing right for their publications
that is what this is truly about
and i'm not even talking about me okay
first of all the attempt to castigate me
as politico staffers apparently have
been doing as a white supremacist are
patently insane i mean totally crazy as
anybody who has ever listened to this
show knows as anybody who's listened to
my speeches knows
i've given like full length 45-minute
dissertations in front of thousands of
people
about how terrible white supremacy is i
did want one at
stanford i think it was last year okay
so like this is not
a thing okay but it's not just me
i happen to know columnists who are
really really anti-trump like so
anti-trump that they piss off mainstream
conservatives on a regular basis
one comes to mind i won't mention his
name
he was asked to be a columnist for the
washington post
and then members of the washington post
staff realize that he believes that
biological men and women exist
he was immediately canceled nope we're
not going to allow him to write for the
washington post anymore
by the way there are columnists for the
washington post like eric wemple where
like you know big publications don't
need to give shapiro a platform he has a
place where you can hear him
i will just note to uh eric wemple of
the washington post i wrote for the
washington post in 2016.
i wrote a piece for them in 2016. so you
might want to talk to your editors over
there dude
in any case the daily beast staffers
were so mad they were so we sent them
a bunch of uh leftist tears tumblers
they're on back order because we have so
many people who want them
we send them some leftist years tumblers
i wouldn't want them to get
their tears all over their laptops where
they are busy journalism all over the
place
according to the daily beast earlier
this month
the beltway news outlet handed over the
keys to its signature news product to
shapiro a talk radio
host and pundit who has long been one of
the most controversial voices in
right-wing media thanks in part to his
incendiary comments about the lgbt
community
muslim black americans and jews who
support democratic politicians
the guest appearance part of a series of
guest appearances by political media
figures including chris hayes and chuck
todd
they're not controversial by the way
chris haye's not controversial at all
right i love how i'm a white right-wing
firebrand chris he's just he's just the
guy
she's the media figure sparked immediate
backlash and criticism from many in the
media industry
including within politico's own newsroom
but the resulting response from politico
brass was unsatisfactory to a number
of employees wow unsatisfactory to the
employees
wow terrible by the way you know what we
call
unsatisfactory to the employees here at
the daily wire
a job that's what we call it
because you're getting paid to do things
that are unsatisfactory to you nearly
every single day
it's called employment gang according to
multiple political insiders familiar
with the situation
the letter to albritton criticized the
decision to publish shapiro
claiming it had demoralized a
substantial portion of the newsroom
oh it demoralized you that's sad what
happened
what happened you couldn't report on how
wonderful joe biden's dog is today
because you were so depressed that i
wrote a piece for you two weeks ago
you fragile little babies seriously my
goodness
i'm so demoralized oh my god i can't
even every time i start to write
every time i start to do my job i think
of the fact that shapiro's name appeared
in politico and i just i can't
i can't i need my i need the ambulance
during a combative meeting on january
14th the day of shapiro's publication
the top editor defended the editorial
decision to irate staffers by claiming
mischief making has already always been
part of politico's secret sauce
the staff letter sent 10 days ago to
albritton maintained that matt kaminski
was the editor had not appropriately
apologized for his responses
additionally referencing an email he
sent to staff on january 15th obtained
and reviewed by the daily beast
by the way leaking internal memos to the
daily beast should be a fireable offense
should it not over a politico maybe you
guys ought to get on that
in the email the top editor expressed
regret for his initial response about
making mischief but reiterated that
publishing shapiro was part of his hopes
to experiment
and mix things up in order to keep
political vital and vibrant to its
readers
in response the letter chinese asked all
britain how shapiro's extensive record
of bigotry can be considered
vibrant or vital because that's the way
this works okay the way that it works is
if you've ever said anything that you
regret
or if you've ever said anything that
people can interpret wrongly as
terrible and horrible and no good and
very bad this means that you must never
be allowed to speak
ever again ever in history it's a
i'm i'm glad politico staffers are so
pure man the woke mob
you either join it or they come after
you that's the way that it works over
there
elsewhere in the notes to their
publisher the politico staffers called
for a commitment to clarify and improve
the outlet's editorial standards an
increase in newsroom diversity uh so
it's just the man letter this is these
guys are going to hold hostage
politico's image so they can get a bunch
of crap that politico doesn't want to do
a commitment to clarify and improve the
outlet's editorial standards which means
we want a veto on what gets printed just
like the new york times
has basically handed over veto power to
the pseudo-journalist and fictionalized
historian nicole hannah jones
an increase in newsroom diversities they
want hiring based on rays an editor's
note
on shapiro's edition of playbook so they
want like a little note at the bottom
saying shapiro's a bigot but we
published him anyway we're really sad
about that but we're not pulling it
and an internal apology for the
management response to staff criticism
of publishing shapiro
despite the 100 plus signatures to the
note some politico staffers stressed to
the daily beast it did not represent the
overall mood
at the publication several of the
company's 300 editorial employees said
they hadn't even heard about the effort
or weren't asked to sign the letter
others said they were encouraged that
kaminsky and other top editors have been
meeting over the past several days
with newsroom employees and attempts to
avoid blow-ups like the shapiro saga
well
i mean i'm so glad that they've been
meeting with the whiniest among them to
avoid
the blow-ups okay all of this speaks to
a broader problem
not just in media but also in social
media so twitter is now launching a new
program
in which community members are going to
be able to warn twitter about other
people saying the bads
twitter on monday according to fox news
has unveiled a new community driven
approach to misleading information on
his platform
allowing users to add notes to tweets
they believe are false in an attempt to
quote unquote add context for other
users oh good
this can't be misused in any way we're
going to crowdsource fact checking
over over twitter wonderful idea
no way that this this goes wrong in any
way it's called
bird watch on bird watch no account and
no tweet is exempt from annotation
meaning users can add context to tweets
posted by news outlets reporters and
elected officials
birdwatch will allow users to identify
information in tweets they believe are
misleading or false
and write notes or notations to those
tweets in a way they feel is providing
informative context
participants will be able to annotate
any tweet once they will have the option
to cite source material in their
annotation including from news outlets
meaning users can annotate one news
outlet suite by citing
other news outlets tweets oh oh good
sounds sounds great so it's a community
driven approach okay so here's the thing
when you have a majoritarian driven
approach to uh
denying particular arguments as
anti-factual
that is the precise opposite of free
speech okay free speech is about
protecting voices
that require protection namely minority
voices generally
twitter instead is going to be like what
if the mob gets you okay that already
exists it's just called
twitter that's all it's just called
twitter twitter explained to fox news
the company is not doing a fact check
with birdwatch
and that is not a true or false tool but
instead a way to quote unquote add
context and this is the way the fact
checkers do it at these major companies
right they no longer just rate whether
your statement is true or false instead
they say they're going to add context in
except when they're trying to not add
context right when they're trying to not
add context then they just don't add the
context
then they just write the statement on on
the pure true and false of the statement
it's pretty incredible
how they do all of this really well done
stuff okay so rupert murdoch who is of
course coming under fire because
fox news has become the focal point of
the left's attempts to silence them
that's not a shock in any way shape or
form of course
because the left has been attempting to
silence fox news literally since
inception
sure murdoch gave a speech the other day
in which he condemned the awful woke
orthodoxy good for him
for those of us in media there's a real
challenge to confront
a wave of censorship that seeks to
silence conversation
to stifle debate and ultimately stop
individuals
and societies from realizing their
potential
this rigidly enforced conformity aided
about it
by so-called social media is a straight
jacket
on sensibility too many people have
fought too hard
in too many places for freedom of speech
to be suppressed by this awful work
orthodoxy
he happens to be correct about this the
goal then is shut down
fox news you have margaret sullivan the
washington post columnist
literally tweeting out media matters
links and fox news advertisers
and and people on the right by the way
going along with some of this stuff
because they're so angry over what
happened on january 6th that they are
willing to go along
but the left's version of everything
that the right says is dangerous and so
we must ban it
the most recent example i saw so last
night media matters
did what they do which is they took
somebody out of context they went on
tucker carlson's show
tucker was making a first amendment
defense and he was saying
okay even the dumbest theories that
people have even the stuff that people
say
that is like the dumbest stuff you still
have a right to think that stuff in the
united states of america and then he
played
a montage of members of the media
basically saying that people who are
associated with the idiotic and
conspiratorial q anon idea
that those people ought to be silenced
and tucker was making the broader
argument not about the veracity of again
the idiotic dangerous and ridiculous
conspiracy theory q anon
i mean it's ridiculous on its face it's
stupid it's in
it's inflammatory and just dumb in every
possible way
that was not tucker's point tucker's
point was you still have a right to
think dumb things in the united states
which
used to be sort of the baseline of
freedom right media matters took that
clip they said he was defending q anon
which he absolutely was not
and members of the right started
tweeting out the clip members of the
right were like oh you know what
you know maybe they have a point here
tucker's bad okay again guys
you're losing the thread you are losing
the thread if you're tweeting out media
matters clips there's a good shot that
you have lost the thread here
it was always a matter of the for the
left it's all about weaponizing it is
all about not not for good-hearted
liberals again there are good-hearted
liberals who i think
differ with with people like me on
impeachment that's fair that's fine
but i think there are a lot of people
who are not liberal who are just
leftists and they are using every
opportunity they can
to quash people who they disagree with
on every single side
and it's disgusting and it's gross and
it's terrible for the country
all right we're going to be back here
later today with an additional hour of
the ben shapiro show in the meantime
head on over to the michael knowles show
disney plus is now censoring classic
films for children under seven
i know if you knew this they're like
taking taking down peter pan
and dumbo so my kids can't watch them
because they are supposedly racially
insensitive
michael will get into that news in
today's show that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench hero
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
president biden extends the pandemic
timeline as
15 days to slow the spread closes in on
a year
disney censors peter pan for political
incorrectness
and lazy teachers justify their refusal
to work by whining about
white supremacy check it out on the
michael knowles show